[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
show you know I don't think too much of
John Bolton Donald Trump's former
National Security advisor and one of the
architects of the 2003 invasion of Iraq
but at least when it comes to one
principle Bolton seems to be uh sticking
to what he says matters and that
principle is that Donald Trump shouldn't
be president that it's bad for Trump to
be president that Trump is dangerous
that Trump is irresponsible that Trump
represents a national security threat
and the latest along those lines is that
John Bolton has vowed to launch a
presidential bid himself to confront
Donald Trump
if he believes it is what is necessary
or would be helpful in
preventing Trump from being president
again he says I wouldn't run as a vanity
candidate if I didn't think I could run
seriously then I wouldn't get in the
race I would get in to win the
nomination and I would do it primarily
on the basis that we need a much
stronger foreign policy
um I'd like to see shermanesque
statements from all the potential
candidates if I don't see that I'm going
to seriously consider getting in
he also says that uh you can't just say
I support the Constitution you have to
say I would oppose the people who would
undercut it he says Trump's statements
with regard to just suspending the
Constitution and making himself
president again are quote disqualifying
for public office I mean that this is
kind of interesting to me Pat in the
sense that
Bolton doesn't seem like the type of guy
who would even talk about this
flippantly if he weren't really thinking
about it and this is the first time ever
hearing about his presidential Ambitions
maybe I just haven't followed Bolton
enough you know uh it's all kind of
silly to me like I get the idea that
there would be an establishment type
Republican candidate who would get into
the race to play spoiler to try to
prevent Trump from getting the
nomination yeah but John Bolton of all
people like are there Bolton supporters
out there are there people who really
want Bolton to become president even the
Republican party is largely moved away
from this war hawkish foreign policy in
recent years and also I do kind of have
to take issue with something that you
said which is that I don't know if
Bolton we can say that Bolton's really
sticking uh to principle here by
opposing Trump when Bolton did work
within the Trump Administration and only
really started to criticize him after
getting fired by Trump like it's more
about principle I think it's more about
vengeance and sticking things off the
wrong side he's sticking to the latest
version of the principle which has been
around for about a year and a half which
is more than we can say for some of the
other people yeah I should I should
soften the principal aspect of it
came up with that principle a few years
ago
ever since he changed to this view two
years ago he's stuck with it pat
absolutely so do you think this is
destined to go the way of like the Joe
Walsh campaign and I dwelled and these
other Republicans who tried to step in
the way from like I definitely feel like
there are Republicans out there who can
give Trump a run for his money Family
Rhonda santis but John Bolton no way I
mean maybe it would kind of make sense
for him to run if there's no other
Republicans in the fields but aside from
that if it is going to be a packed field
of candidates he just shouldn't even
bother yeah and I mean when you look at
the betting markets right now for the
Republican nomination DeSantis is
leading followed by Trump that's 70 plus
percent right there
and then you've got Nikki Haley I don't
know that I mean Bolton maybe can
compete with Nikki Haley Mike Pence I
think Bolton can hold his own against
Pence
Glenn Younkin Tim Scott Mike Pompeo yeah
but these people you know they're
they're down at the very very bottom I
don't know how Bolton actually wins in a
national campaign against Trump in a
primary and I don't know how Bolton
competes with DeSantis either to be
perfectly Frank
right foreign policy would have to be
front and center like maybe the U.S gets
involved in another war or there's some
sort of attack or something and
everyone's focused on whatever our new
enemy is that's the only lane and even
then I would have a tough time imagining
that John Bolton of all people could win
the Republican primary and then become
the president uh it's funny you
mentioned Mike Pompeo he's another one
of these names that gets thrown out
there but does he actually have a
supporter base are there people who
actually want Pompeo to become president
outside of I've never met those people
outside of the establishment I I've
never heard of them either even Nikki
Haley I know like she um gets floated
out there because you know
oh boy
elegant Circles of Specialties important
these days because like they don't have
too many people like that to point to so
you know she gets you know a lot of
recognition as a potential candidate but
also with her I don't think there's a
lot of actual Nikki Haley supporters I
agree with you and Pat having a bit of a
glitch there in his connection but
fortunately coming back without us
missing too much of what he said
thankfully uh I agree on the Nikki Haley
thing 100 let's talk about credit card
debt oh sorry debt
um Americans are piling up credit card
debt reports NPR and it could prove
costly in the long run the average
credit card user is now carrying a
balance uh or was carrying a balance of
fifty four hundred dollars last fall
according to TransUnion that's up 13
from 2021 so on average people's credit
card balances at any given time are 13
higher than they were in 2021. that's a
big change from the first year of the
pandemic because a lot of people were
staying home and not spending money in
many areas that they formerly did they
were actually paying down credit card
debt and that was an interesting change
saving Rate rates were higher Etc now
people are coming back to doing things
more inflation is outpacing income
growth in many cases and so just by the
sheer math of it people are going to
debt credit card debt usually to cover
day-to-day expenses and it could be over
the long run a very bad thing you know
one of the things we talk about over on
the finance channel is that there's good
debts and bad debts and there's debts
you take on for assets that appreciate
like for example a mortgage and that
doesn't mean a mortgage is always the
right thing and you want to look at the
interest rate there's all these caveats
but the point is charging everyday
things and then taking months to pay
them off or or years but then every
month you have to keep charging those
everyday things means that you end up
paying for example for groceries from
last year and six months ago and two
months ago and this month all in the
same month month in interest payments
and that's a very bad thing in general
the concern of course Pat
is that this can be cumulative
and it can start to overtake people's
budgets to the point that it can cause
at the at the macro economic level it
can cause a recession because people
have no more credit available to buy
stuff because their credit cards are
already maxed based on things that
they've previously charged and at the
micro level obviously it's not good for
people's personal finance finances and
household budget so something needs to
turn this around at some point
do you think this could be a warning
sign for the economy like we talk all
the time here about how you have to look
at all these different indicators and
right now job numbers are strong the
stock market is it could be better but
it's okay it's holding up right
inflation's going in the right direction
which is downward of course we still
have to deal with the interest rates so
like you look at you know 10 different
economic indicators and you come up with
a general picture of how the economy is
doing but this one does kind of stand
out and maybe goes to show that the
economy isn't doing so well or could uh
be you know bad in the coming years or
so because if people max out their
credit lines they don't have extra money
to spend well then all of a sudden
they're not going to be able to
participate in the economy as much maybe
they default on the debt that they have
and you know their personal finances
become a wreck if this happens at scale
then that could spell disastrous for the
American economy I'm not making any
predictions here but when I see
something like this I do think it's a
little bit troubling that's the concern
you know there's these more very there's
these really specific indicators that
some like to say here's a much better
signal about what's coming in the
economy one that's sometimes looked at
is how many people are more than 90 days
behind on car payments that's one that
we've talked about before that some
people say this really gives you a sign
of what's coming because it starts to
point towards vehicle repossessions
which prevents people from getting to
work and you know sort of the carry-on
effects I still don't think there's any
one indicator that really tells us the
truth about what's coming but certainly
people taking on more and more credit
card debt you would think isn't isn't a
good sign now the Counterpoint to this
is the following
people sometimes take on more debt when
they are very confident about the state
of the economy so if you wanted to come
up with an optimistic spin on this it
would be people aren't going into more
debt on credit cards because they
necessarily have to but they're choosing
to extend themselves because they are
rationally assessing the economy is
going to be good my job prospects are
good I'm going to make more money so I
can afford to make this decision it's
very uh rose rose colored glasses in the
sense that most people don't make credit
card decisions necessarily in that way
yeah I don't know about that one like I
could see a business deciding to take a
loan thinking that the economy is going
to be in a good position and so they'll
be able to make a solid return on
investment from that money and weighing
in how they think the economy is doing
all these different factors but the
average person putting money on their
credit card I don't think it's mostly
that I don't think they're thinking
about what the economy is going to be
like in the next couple of years yeah it
could simply be they need to pay for
stuff they don't have the money to do it
they have their credit card available
that's their only option
um so unfortunately I don't think this
is something we can really uh you know
view through rose-colored glasses no
actually it's cause for concern very
often the simplest explanation which
requires the fewest assumptions is the
preferable one unless we have some
really specific reason to to favor a
more complicated explanation so we'll
continue tracking that number this is
kind of cool Katie Porter congresswoman
Katie Porter who I think is absolutely
fantastic she has announced that she is
going to run for Senate she's in the
house she's running for Senate this
would be the seat currently held by
Dianne Feinstein who has already said
she's not going to seek I'm sorry who
has not said whether she plans to seek
re-election in 2024. so there's the
potential that Katie Porter would be
facing off against Dianne Feinstein in a
primary now my bet Pat is that Dianne
Feinstein does not run for re-election
in 2024. she's 89 years old right now
she will presumably be somewhere between
90 and 91 at the time of the 2024
election which would push her to being
around 95 at the end of that next term
she's been in the Senate a very long
time time it's not about pushing people
out I just think she's not going to run
for reelection and Katie Porter would be
a great person to take this seat
yeah I think it's entirely possible that
Feinstein wants to run again but her
staffers and the Insiders over there
will push her not to run because 91 is
getting up there especially for an
elected member of the Senate I know that
Chuck Grassley has done it but it's
really time to wrap it up I think at
that age and also there's been the
questions about Dianne Feinstein's
cognitive State at the moment which
probably is not going to improve over
the next couple of years if we're being
realistic so I think with Katie Porter
announcing her run and doing so this
early like two years pretty much before
the election maybe that's part of her
way of trying to be like the only
candidate in the field at least for now
or at least you know push defianstein
away from from running herself yeah and
Pat it but just so people know Pat is
not bringing up the cognitive thing
simply because Dianne Feinstein is is
almost 90. there are real concerns about
what's going on with her including the
fact that during a number of different
hearings she has asked verbatim the same
question multiple times and seems
completely unaware that she was doing it
and then a bunch of other reports from
inside her office which are sort of
escaping my memory now but we've talked
about before you're mentioning that
specifically because of Dianne Feinstein
not because of her age generally exactly
yep there have been a couple of stories
about how there's been questions raised
based on the things that she's done you
can see it in those Congressional
testimonies she'll meet people and then
shortly after see them again and not
realize that she had met them before or
different types like that it's not
making fun of it or anything like that
it's just one of these things where this
is a job that requires you to be on your
A-game and if you are not able to do
that for one reason or another then it's
maybe time to look elsewhere speaking by
the way a little bit about the 2024
senate elections the 2024 senate
elections
are they what do we even say they're a
really big deal I think is the way I
would put it the the way that it is
looking right now is uh based on the
number of seats that are up Democrats
have 20 seats up in 2024 Republicans
have 11 seats up and independents
meaning Kirsten Cinema Bernie Sanders
and Angus King also are up for
re-election those are the 34 seats that
are up in 2024. uh if you consider that
those three Independents caucus with
Democrats Democrats have 23 seats to
defend whereas Republicans have 11. now
that doesn't if you only look at that
you might say well it's potentially much
worse for Democrats than for Republicans
you have to also have to look at how
many seats are safe and that's sort of a
different calculation which I'm not
necessarily going to do right now but
the 2024 senate election is a is a major
major deal particularly because it
coincides also with the presidential
election
right it's not the best thing for
Democrats looking at how many seats they
have up for re-election right now but if
you consider the fact that for one we've
been in this situation before I don't
know if it was 2018 or 2020 where we had
a ton of uh of our Democratic senators
up for re-election and they actually did
okay
um so you know if we've done it once
maybe we can do it again also it's a
presidential election year so much is
going to uh be determined by who's at
the top of the ticket if Biden's able to
sail to re-election then that stands to
reason that maybe Democrats are able to
hold a bunch of seats maybe even hold on
to control of the Senate whereas if
Republicans are able to sweep in there I
don't think we have any chance at all at
taking the Senate
um so it's going to depend largely on
the presidential candidate
um just back to this California thing
real quick do you think that there's a
chance that maybe someone like rokana or
Adam Schiff or another one of these big
names out of California will run for
that seat as well because I have to
imagine with Katie Porter being more of
a Progressive some establishment
Centrist type of candidate is going to
run as well it's certainly possible and
that would be interesting although then
it's you know like what is the wisdom of
having multiple California members of
Congress fighting for the same senate
seat you can't run for both Congress and
Senate at the same time it seems
potentially like a bad idea
well I'm hoping that now at this point
rokana doesn't run I mean I'm not saying
that he's any better or worse than Katie
Porter but Porter has already announced
and so maybe she's boxed him out I just
don't want two progressives to be
running against the Centrist Adam Schiff
I'm honestly not even too sure about
what his politics are like he's always
in the news because of uh you know his
anti-trump stances on things and like
maybe that's the game he's trying to
play to appeal to the Democrats who just
hate Trump and don't care as much about
the policy but I could also see him
running and maybe it'll be a porter
versus shift primary another but by the
way Schiff is 62 years old I would have
guessed he was like 52 honestly he's 60.
years old yeah I know I think it's olive
oil it's something about special olive
oil I don't know I'm gonna have to eat
whatever he's having acai berries and
Soylent I would have guessed like late
40s maybe I know four I would have
guessed 49 to 52 and he's 62 years old
assuming assuming my information is
correct all right everybody we'll see
you on the Town Hall at 6 p.m today
looking forward to it